The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
LORNA GIBSON: OK, so we
should probably start.
So last time we finished up
talking about energy absorption
in foamy cellular materials.
And today I wanted
to start a new topic.
We're going to talk
about sandwich panels.
So sandwich panels have
two stiff, strong skins
that are separated by some
sort of lightweight core.
So the skins are typically,
say, a metal like aluminum,
or some sort of fiber composite.
And the core is usually some
sort of cellular material.
Sometimes it's an
engineering honeycomb.
Sometimes it's a foam.
Sometimes it's balsa wood.
And the idea is that
what you're doing
with the core is you're using
a light material to separate
the faces, and if you
think about an I-beam--
so if you remember when
we talk about bending
and we talk about I-beams, the
whole idea is that in bending,
you want to increase
the moment of inertia.
So you want to make as
much material as far
away from the middle
of the beam as possible
to increase the
moment of inertia.
So if you think about an I-beam,
you put the flanges far apart
with the web, and that
increases the moment of inertia.
And the sandwich
panels and the sandwich
beams essentially
do the same thing,
but they're using a lightweight
core instead of a web.
And so the idea is you
use a lightweight core.
It separates the faces.
It increases the
moment of inertia.
But you don't add a
whole lot of weight
because you've got this
lightweight core in the middle.
So I brought some examples
that I'll pass around
and we can play with.
So these are some examples up
on the screen, and some of those
I have down here.
So for instance, the
top-- turn my little gizmo
on-- the top left here, this
is a helicopter rotor blade,
and that has a
honeycomb core in it.
This is an aircraft flooring
panel that has a honeycomb core
and has carbon fiber faces.
So that's this thing here.
I'll pass that
around in a minute.
This is a downhill ski.
This has aluminum faces and
a polyurethane foam core.
And that's the ski here.
And it's quite
common in skis now
to have these sandwich panels.
This is a little piece
of a small sailing boat.
It had, I think, glass fiber
faces and a balsa wood core.
And I don't know
if any of you sail,
but MIT has new sailing boats.
Do you sail?
AUDIENCE: I do not
much these days.
LORNA GIBSON: OK,
but those little tech
dinghies that you
see out in the river,
those have sandwich
panel holes to them.
So those are little
sandwich panels.
This is an example
from a building panel.
This has a dry wall face and a
plywood face and a foam core,
and the idea with
panels for buildings
is that usually they use a
foam core because the foam has
some thermal insulation.
So as well as sort of
separating the faces
and having a
structural role, it has
a role in thermally
insulating the building.
The foams are a
little less efficient
than using a honeycomb core.
So for the same weight,
you get a stiffer structure
with a honeycomb core
than a foam core.
But if you want thermal
insulation as well as
a structural requirement,
then the foam cores are good.
And these are a couple examples
of sandwiches in nature.
This is the human skull.
And your skull is a
sandwich of two dense layers
of the compact bone,
and you can see
there's a little thin layer of
the trabecular bone in between.
So your head is like a sandwich,
your skull is like a sandwich.
And I don't know if I'll
get to it next time,
but in the next
couple of lectures,
I'm going to talk a little
bit about sandwich panels
in nature, sandwich
shells in nature.
You see this all the time.
And this is a bird wing, here.
And so you can see
there's got the dense bone
on the top and the
bottom, and it's
got this kind of almost
trust-like structure
in the middle.
And obviously birds want
to reduce their weight
because they want to fly,
so reducing the weight's
very important.
And so this is one of the ways
that birds reduce their weight,
is by having a sandwich
kind of structure.
So I have a couple
of things here.
These are the two
panels at the top there.
This is the ski, and you
can yank those around.
I also have a few panels
that people at MIT have made.
And I have the pieces
that they're made from.
So you can see how effective
the sandwich thing is.
So this was made by a
guy called Dirk Moore.
He was a graduate student
in ocean engineering.
And it has aluminum faces and
a little thin aluminum core.
So you can see, if you try and
bend that with your fingers,
you really can't bend it
any noticeable amount.
And this panel here is
roughly the same thickness
of the face on that.
And you can see how
easy it is for me
to bend that-- very easy.
And this is the same kind
of thing as the core.
It's thicker than
that core, but you
can see how easy it is
for me to bend this, too.
So each of the pieces is
not very stiff at all.
But when you put them all
together, it's very stiff.
So that's really
the beauty of this.
You can have
lightweight components,
and by putting them
together in the right way,
they're quite stiff.
So here's another example here.
This is a panel that one of
my students, Kevin Chang made.
And this has actually already
been broken a little bit,
so it's not quite as
stiff as it used to be.
And you can kind of
hear, it squeaks.
But you can feel that and
see how stiff that is.
And this is the face panel here.
And you can see, I can bend
that quite easily with my hands.
Doodle-doot.
And then this is
the core piece here.
And again, this
is very flexible.
So it's really about putting
all those pieces together.
So you get this
sandwich construction
and you get that effect, OK?
[? Oop-loo. ?]
All right, so what
we're going to do
is first of all look at the
stiffness of these panels,
calculate their deflection.
We're going to look at the
minimum weight design of them.
So we're going to
look at how for,
say, given materials
in a given span,
how do we minimize the weight of
the beam for a given stiffness?
And then we're going to look
at the stresses in the sandwich
beams.
So there's going to be one
set of stresses in the faces,
and a different kind of stress
distribution in the core.
So we'll look at the
stress distribution.
And then we'll talk
about failure modes,
how these things
can fail, and then
how to figure out which
failure mode is dominant, which
one occurs at the lowest load.
And then we'll look at
optimizing the design,
minimizing the design for a
certain strength and stiffness.
So we're not going to get all
that way through everything
today, but we'll kind
of make a start on that.
OK.
So let me start.
So the idea here is we have two
stiff, strong skins, or faces,
separated by a lightweight core.
And the idea is that by
separating the faces,
you increase the
moment of inertia
with little increase in weight.
So these are particularly good
if you want to resist bending,
or if you want to
resist buckling.
Because both of those involve
the moment of inertia.
And they work like an I-beam.
So the faces of the sandwich are
like the flanges of the I-beam,
and the core is like the web.
And the faces are typically
made of either fiber reinforced
composites or metals.
So typically, something
like aluminum,
usually you're trying
to reduce the weight
if you use these things, so a
lightweight metal like aluminum
is sometimes used.
And the cores are usually
honeycombs, or foams, or balsa.
And when they use balsa
wood, what they do
is-- I brought a piece of
balsa here-- what they do
is they would take
a block like this
and chop it into
pieces around here.
And then they would lay
those pieces on a cloth mat.
So typically the pieces are
maybe two inches by two inches.
They lay them on a cloth
mat, and because they're not
one monolithic piece, they
can then shape that mat
to curved shapes.
So it doesn't have to
be just a flat panel.
They can curve it around a
curved surface if they want.
So we'll say the
honeycombs are lighter
than the foams for a given
stiffness or strength.
But the foams provide
thermal insulation as well as
a mechanical support.
And the overall mechanical
properties of the honeycomb
depend on the properties
of each of the two parts,
of the faces and
the core, and also
the geometry of
the whole thing--
how thick's the core, how
thick's the face, how dense is
the core?
That kind of thing.
And typically, the panel has
to have some required stiffness
or strength.
And often what you
want to do is minimize
the weight for that required
stiffness or strength.
So often these panels are
used in some sort of vehicle,
like we talked about the
sailboat, or like a helicopter,
or like an airplane.
They're also used in like
refrigerated trucks--
they would have a foam
core because they'd
want the thermal insulation.
So if you were going to use
it in some sort of a vehicle,
you want to reduce the
mass of the vehicle
and you want to have the
lightest panel that you can.
Yup?
AUDIENCE: So if you
saw the base material
and you'd have the
[INAUDIBLE] sandwich
panel, that piece [INAUDIBLE]
the sandwich panel
with something
[? solid ?] in the middle?
LORNA GIBSON: Well--
AUDIENCE: So, as we're getting
[INAUDIBLE] aluminum piece
that's was as thick
as a sandwich panel.
LORNA GIBSON: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
LORNA GIBSON: Oh, well, if
you have the solid aluminum
piece that was as
thick as the sandwich,
it's going to be
stiffer, but it's
going to be a lot, lot heavier.
So the stiffness per unit
weight would not be as good.
OK?
So we're going to calculate the
stiffness in just one minute.
And then we're going to look at
how we minimize the weight, OK?
OK.
So what I'm going
to do is set this up
as kind of a general thing.
We're just going to look at
sandwich beams rather than
plates, just because
it's simpler.
But the plates, everything
we say for the beams
basically applies to the plates.
The equation's just a
little bit more complicated.
So we're going to start
with analyzing beams.
And I'm just going
to start with a beam,
say, in three-point bending.
So there's my faces there.
Boop.
And I've made it
kind of more stumpy
than it would be in real life,
just because it makes it easier
to draw it.
And then if I look at
it the other way on,
it would look
something like that.
So say there's some load P here.
Say the span of the beam is l.
Say the load's in the middle,
so each of the supports just
sees a load of P/2.
And then let me just define some
geometrical parameters here.
I'm going to say the
width of the beam is b.
And I'm going to say the
face thicknesses are each t.
So the thickness
of each face is t.
And the thickness of
the core is c, OK?
So that's just sort
of definitions.
And I'm going to say the
face has a set of properties,
the core has a
set of properties,
and then the solid from
which the core is made
has another set of properties.
So the face properties
that we're going to use
are a density of the face.
We'll call that row f.
The modulus of the face, Ef,
and some sort of strength
of the face, let's imagine
it's aluminum and it yields,
that would be sigma
y of the face.
And then the core
similarly is going
to have a density, rho star c.
It's going to have
a modulus, E star c.
And it's going to
have some strength,
I'm going to call sigma star c.
And then the solid
from which the core
is made is going to
have a density row
s, a modulus Es, and some
strength, sigma ys, OK?
So the core is going
to be some kind
of cellular material, a
honeycomb, or a foam, or balsa.
And typically, the
modulus of the core
is going to be a lot less
than the modulus of the face.
So I'm just going to say here
that the E star c is typically
much greater than Ef.
And we're going to
use that later on.
So we're going to derive
some equations, for example,
for an equivalent flexural
rigidity for the section, an Ei
equivalent.
And that has several terms.
But if we can say
the core stiffness
is much less than
the face thickness,
and also if we can say the
core-- the stiffness is less
and also the
thickness of the core
is much greater than the
thickness of the face,
a lot of the expressions
we're going to use simplify.
So we're going to make
those assumptions.
So let me just draw
the shear diagram here.
So V is shear, so that's
the shear diagram.
We have some load
P/2 at the support.
There's no other load
applied until we get to here.
Than the shear diagram goes down
by P, so we're at minus P/2.
Then there's no load here,
so this just stays constant,
and then we go back up to 0.
And then let me just draw
bending moment diagram.
The bending moment
diagram for this
is just going to
look like a triangle.
Remember, if we integrate
the shear diagram,
we get the bending
moment diagram.
And that maximum moment
there is going to Pl over 4.
OK.
So initially, I'm going to
calculate the deflections.
And I don't really need
those diagrams for that,
but then I'm going to
calculate the stresses,
and I'm going to need those
diagrams for the stresses.
So just kind of keep
those in mind for now.
So to calculate the
deflections, sandwich panels
are a little bit different
from homogeneous beams.
In a sandwich panel,
the core is not
very stiff compared
to the faces.
And we've got some shear
stresses acting on the thing.
And the shear stresses are
largely carried by the core.
So the core is actually
going to shear,
and there's going to be
a significant deflection
of the core and shear as
well as the overall bending
of the whole panel.
So you have to count for that.
So we're going to have a bending
term and a shear term-- that's
what those two terms are there.
So we're going to say there's a
bending deflection and a shear
deflection.
And that shearing
deflection arises
from the core being sheared and
the fact that the core, say,
Young's modulus or
also the shear modulus,
is quite a bit less
than the face modulus.
So if you think of the core
as being much more compliant
than the face, then
the core is going
to have some deflection
from that shear stress.
OK, so we're going to
start out with this term
here, the bending term.
And if I just had a homogeneous
beam in three-point bending,
the central
deflections-- so these
are all the central deflections
I'm calculating here-- with Pl
cubed over it turns out to be
48 is the number, and divided
by EI.
And because we don't have
a homogeneous beam here,
I'm going to call
that equivalent EI.
And to make it a little
bit more general,
instead of putting
48, that number,
I'm just going to
put a constant B1.
And that B1 constant
is just going
to depend on the
loading geometry.
So any time I have a
concentrated load on a beam,
the deflection's always
Pl cubed over EI,
and then the sum number in the
denominator and that number
just depends on the
loading configuration.
So for three-point
bending, it's 48.
For the flexion of a
cantilever, B1 would be 3.
So think of that
as just a number
that you can work out for
the particular loading
configuration.
So here we'll say B1 is
just a constant that depends
on the loading configuration.
And I'll say, for example, for
three-point bending, B1 is 48.
For a cantilever end
deflection, then B1 would be 3.
So it's just a number.
So the next thing we
have to figure out
is what's the EI equivalent.
So if this was just
a homogeneous beam,
and it was rectangular, E
would just be E of the material
and I would be the width
B times the height H
cubed divided by 12.
So here we don't quite
have that because we
have two different materials.
So here we have to use something
called the parallel axis
theorem, which I'm hoping
you may have seen somewhere
in calculus, maybe?
But, yeah, somebody
is nodding yes.
OK, so what we do,
what we want to do
is get the equivalent EI--
I'm going to put it back up,
don't panic-- of this
thing here, right?
So I want-- this is
the neutral axis here,
and I want the EI about
that neutral axis there.
So, OK, you happy?
There.
OK, so I've got a
term for the core.
OK, the core, that is the
middle of the core, right?
So for the core, it's just
going to be E of the core times
bc cubed over 12.
Remember, for a rectangular
section, it's bh cubed over 12
is the moment of inertia.
And here our height for
the core is just c, OK?
And then if I took
the moment of inertia
for, say, one face about
its own centroidal axis,
I would get E of the face
now times bt cubed over 12.
So that's taking the
moment of inertia
of one face about the
middle of the face.
And I have two of those, right?
Because I have two faces.
And the parallel axis
theorem tells you
what the moment of inertia is
going to be if you move it,
not to the-- you don't use
the centroid of the area,
but you use some
other parallel axis.
And what that tells you
to do is take the area
that you're interested in--
so the area of the face is bt,
and you multiply by the square
of the distance between the two
axes that you're interested in.
Oop, yeah.
Let me change my
little brackets.
Boop.
So, oop-a-doop-a-doop.
Maybe I'll stick this, make a
little sketch over here again.
OK, all right.
So this term here,
Ef bt cubed over 12,
that would be the moment of
inertia of this piece here,
about the axis that goes through
the middle of that, right?
Its own centroidal axis.
But what I want to
do is I want to know
what the moment of inertia of
this piece is about this axis
here.
This is the neutral axis.
So let's call this
the centroidal axis.
And the parallel
axis theorem tells me
what I do is I take the
area of this little thing
here, so that's the
b times t, and I
multiply by the square of the
distance between those two
axes.
So the distance between those
axes is just c plus t over 2,
and I square it.
And then I multiply
that whole thing by 2
because I've got two faces.
Are we good?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
LORNA GIBSON: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The center
[INAUDIBLE] and the [INAUDIBLE],
are those Ed's or Ef's?
LORNA GIBSON: These are Ef's
because this is the face now,
right?
So this term here
is for the core.
So here the core is E star c.
And these two Ef's are
for the face up there, OK?
Because you have to
account for the modulus
of the material of the
bit that you're getting
the moment of inertia for.
Are we good?
OK.
So now I'm just
going to simplify
these guys a little bit.
Doodle-doodle-doodle-do-doot.
OK?
So I've just
multiplied the twos,
and maybe I'll just write down
here this is the parallel axis
theorem.
Doot-doot-doot.
Yes, sorry?
AUDIENCE: So for the term
that comes from the parallel
axis theorem, why do we
only consider Ef and not
[INAUDIBLE].
LORNA GIBSON:
Because I'm taking--
what I'm looking at-- so the
very first term, this guy,
here--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, [INAUDIBLE].
LORNA GIBSON: Accounts
for this, right?
And these two terms both
account for the face.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK,
so the face acting--
LORNA GIBSON: Yeah,
about this axis.
So the parallel
axis theorem says
you take the moment of
inertia of your area
about its own centroidal
axis, and then you
add this term here.
But it's really referring
to that face, OK?
Let me scoot that down
and then scoot over here.
And this is where we get to
say the modulus of the face
is much greater than
the modulus of the core.
And also, typically
c, the core thickness,
is much greater than
t, the face thickness.
So if that's true,
then it turns out
this term is small
compared to that one.
And also this term is
small compared to this one.
And also this term,
instead of having
c plus t squared, if c
is big compared to t,
then I can just call
it c squared, OK?
So you can see here,
if Ec is small,
then this is going to be
small compared to these.
If t is small, then this
guy is going to be small.
So even though it
looks ugly, many times
we can make this
simpler approximation.
OK, so we can just
approximate it
as Ef times btc squared over 2.
So then this bending term
here, we've got everything
we need now to get
that bit there.
So the next bit we want to get
is the shearing deflection.
So what's the shearing
deflection equal to?
So say we just thought
about the core,
and all we're
interested in here is
what's the deflection
of the core and shear?
And so say that's P/2,
that's P/2, that's l/2.
We'll say that's-- oops.
That's our shearing
deflection there.
We can say the shear
stress in the core
is going to equal the shear
modulus times the shear strain,
so we can say P over
the area of the core
is going to be proportional
to the Young's modulus times
delta s over l.
And let's not worry about
the constant just yet.
So delta s is going to be
proportional to-- well, let
me [? make it ?]
proportional at this point.
Delta s is going to equal Pl
divided by some other constant
that I'm going to
call B2, and divided
by the shear
modulus of the core,
and essentially the
area of the core.
And here B2 is another constant.
So again, B2 just depends on
the loading configuration.
Yeah, this is a little bit
of an approximation here,
but I'm just going
to leave it at that.
OK, so then we have
these two terms
and we just add them up
to get the final thing.
Start another board.
OK.
So that would give us an
equation for the deflection.
And one thing to note here
is that this shear modulus
of the core, if
the core is a foam,
then we have an
equation for that.
We also could use an
equation if it's a honeycomb.
But I'm just going to
write for foam cores.
Whoops.
This is for-- that will be
for open-cell foam cores.
Oops, don't want to--
and get rid of that.
We won't update
just now, thank you.
OK, so the next thing
I want to think about
is how we would minimize the
weight for a given stiffness.
So say if we're
given a stiffness,
we're given P over delta, so
I could take out the two P's
here.
If I divide it through
by P, delta over P
would be the compliance, P over
delta would be the stiffness.
So imagine that you're given
the face and core materials,
and you're told how
long the span has to be,
you're told how wide
the beam is going to be,
and you're told the
loading configuration.
So you know if it's three-point
bending, or four-point bending,
or a cantilever--
whatever it is.
And you might be asked to find
the core thickness, the face
thickness, and the core density
that would minimize the weight.
So I have a little
schematic here.
I don't know if you're
going be able to read it.
So I'm going to walk
through it and then
I'll write things on the board.
Whoops, hit the wrong button.
OK, so we start with the
weight equation here.
The weight's obviously
the sum of the weight
of the faces, the weight of the
core, so those two terms there.
So I'll write that
down in a minute.
And then we have the
stiffness constraint here.
So this equation here
is just this equation
that I have down here
on the board, OK?
Then what you do is you solve
that stiffness constraint
for the density of the core.
So this equation
here just solves--
we're solving this equation
here in terms of the density,
and we get the density by
substituting in this equation
here for the shear
modulus of the core.
So you substitute that there.
It's kind of a messy
thing, but you solve
that in terms of the density.
Then you put that
version of the density
here in terms of this
weight equation up here.
So then you've eliminated
the density out of the weight
equation, now you've
just got it in terms
of the other variables.
And then you take the partial
derivative of the weight
with respect to
the core thickness
c, set that equal to 0, and
you take the partial derivative
of the weight with respect
to the face thickness, t,
and you set that equal to 0.
And that then gives you two
equations and two unknowns.
You've got the core thickness
and the face thickness
are the two unknowns.
And you've got
the two equations,
so then you solve those.
So the value you get for
the core thickness is then
the optimum, so it's going to be
some function of the stiffness,
the material
properties you started
with in the beam geometry.
And similarly, you get some
equation for the optimum face
thickness, t.
And again, it's a
function of the stiffness
and the material properties
in the beam geometry.
Then you take those two
values for c and t, those two
optimum values, and plug it
back into this equation here,
and get the optimum value
of the core density.
And so what you end
up are three equations
for the optimal values of
the core thickness, the face
thickness, and the
core density in terms
of the required stiffness, the
material properties, and then
the loading geometry.
So I'm going to write down
some more notes, because I'll
put this on the Stellar site.
But it's hard to read just here.
So let me write it down and I'll
also write out the equations so
that you have the
equations for calculating
those optimum values.
So before I do that, though,
one of the interesting things
though is if you figure
out the optimal values
of the core thickness
and the face
thickness and the core density,
and you substitute it back
into the weight,
and you calculate
this is the weight of the
face relative to the weight
of the core, no matter
what the geometry is,
and what the loading
configuration is,
the weight of the face
is always a quarter
of the weight of the core.
So the ratio of
how much material
is in the core and
the face is constant,
regardless of the core-- of
the loading configuration.
And this is the
bending deflection
relative to the
total deflection.
It's always 1/3.
And the shearing
deflection relative
to the total deflection
is always 2/3.
So regardless of how
you set things up,
the ratio of what
weight the face
is relative to the core and the
amount of shearing and bending
deflections is always a
constant at the optimum.
OK, so let's say we're given
the face and the core materials.
So that means we're given
their material property, too.
And say we're given the
beam length and width
and the loading configuration.
So that means we're given
those constants, B1 and B2.
If I told you it was
three-point bending,
you would know
what B1 and B2 are.
So then what you need to do
is find the core thickness, c,
the face thickness, t, and
the core density, rho c,
to minimize the
weight of the beam.
So there's two faces, so
the weight of the face
is 2 rho f g times btl.
And then the weight of the
core is rho c g times bcl.
So I'm going to
write down the steps
and then I'll write
down the solution.
So you solve.
So you put this equation for
the shear modulus of the core
into here, and
then you rearrange
this equation in terms of
the density of the core here.
So you have an equation for
the core density in terms
of that stiffness, and then you
solve the partial derivatives
of the weight
equation with respect
to the core thickness, c,
and put that equal to 0.
And then the partial
of dw [? over ?] dt
and set that to 0.
And if you do that,
you can then solve
for the optimal values of the
face and core thicknesses.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
for weight, what is g?
LORNA GIBSON: Gravity.
AUDIENCE: OK.
LORNA GIBSON: Just density
is mass, mass times gravity--
weight.
That's all it is.
And then you've got a
version of this that's
in terms of the core density.
You can substitute those
values of the optimum face
and core thicknesses
into that equation
and get the optimum
core density.
And then in the final equations,
you get, when you do all that,
and I'm going to make
them all dimensionless,
so this is the core
thickness normalized
by the span of the beam is
equal to this thing, here.
So you can see each of
these parameters here,
the design parameters that we're
calculating the optimum of.
I've grouped the constants
B1 and B2 together
that describe the
loading configuration
so you'd be given those.
C2 is this constant--
oop, which I just
rubbed off-- that relates the
shear modulus of the foam core.
So you'd be given that.
These are the material
properties of the-- you
know, say, it's a
polyurethane foam core,
this would be the density
of the polyurethane.
Say it's aluminum
faces, that would
be the density of the aluminum.
so you'd be given that.
You'd be given the
stiffnesses of the two
materials, the solid from which
the core is made and the face
material.
And then this is the stiffness
here that you're given,
just divided by the width of
the beam, B. So the stiffness,
you'd be given the width B. So
you're given all those things,
then you could calculate what
that optimum design would be.
So the next slide here just
shows some experiments.
And these were
done on sandwiches
with aluminum faces and a
rigid polyurethane foam core.
And here we knew
what the relationship
was for the shear modulus.
We measured that.
And what we did here was
we designed the beams
to all have the same
stiffness, and they all
had the same span in
the width, B, then we
kept one parameter
at the optimum value
and we varied the other ones.
So here, on this beam,
this set of beams here,
the density was at the optimum.
And we varied the
core thickness,
and we varied the
face thickness,
and the solid line was our model
or our sort of optimization.
And the little X's
were the experiments.
So you can see there's
pretty good agreement there.
Then the second set here,
we kept the face thickness
at the optimum value and we
varied the core thickness,
we varied the core density.
So the same thing, the solid
line is the sort of theory
and the X's are the experiments.
And here we had the core
thickness of the optimum value,
and we varied the face
thickness and the core density.
So you can kind of see
how you can see this here.
And over here, just
because I forgot to say it,
this is the stiffness per
unit weight, over here, OK?
So these are the optimum
designs here, all right?
So there was pretty
good agreement
between these calculations and
what we measured on some beams.
Do I need to write
anything down?
Do you think you've got that?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I was just going to
ask, for the optimum design
column that you have
there, do those numbers
like fall out of these
equations if you do the math?
LORNA GIBSON: They do, yeah.
I mean, it's-- yeah, exactly.
So if you remember the
equation we had for the weight,
so the weight is equal to 2
rho f gbtl plus the density
of the core, bcl, so if you plug
these things into there, then--
so this is the way to the face,
that's the way to the core,
then it drops out
to be a quarter.
So it's kind of magical.
I mean, you have this big,
long, complicated gory thing,
and then, poof,
everything disappears
except a factor of 1/4.
And the same for the
bending deflection.
So we had those
two terms, so there
was the bending and the shear.
If you just calculate
each of those terms
and take the ratio
of 1 over the total,
or the one over the
other, everything
drops out except that number.
So that's why I pointed
it out, because it seemed
kind of amazing that
everything would drop out
except for that one thing.
OK, so then the next
thing-- so that's
the stiffness in
optimizing the stiffness.
Are we happy-ish?
Yeah?
OK.
So the next thing--
oh, well, let's see.
I don't think I
need to write any.
I think if you have that
graph, I don't really
need to write much down.
So the next thing then is the
strength of the sandwich beams.
So let me get rid of that.
You guys OK?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
LORNA GIBSON: Yeah, but you're
shaking your head like this
is very, very helpful for me.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
LORNA GIBSON: Oh OK, that's OK.
LORNA GIBSON: That's
OK, you can do that.
I don't mind.
But as long as you don't
have questions for me.
OK, and so the
first step in trying
to figure out
about this strength
is we need to figure out
the stresses in the beams.
So we need to find out
about the stresses.
And we're going to
have normal stresses
and we're going to
have shear stresses.
So I'm going to do the
normal stresses first
and then we'll do
the shear stresses.
So you do this in
a way that's just
analogous to how you
figure out the stresses
in a homogeneous beam.
So we'll say the stresses
in the face-- normally it
would be My over
I. M is the moment,
y is the distance
from the neutral axis,
I is the moment of inertia.
So this time, instead of
having a moment of inertia,
we have this equivalent
moment of inertia.
And we multiply
by E of the face.
So you can think of this as
being the strain essentially.
And then you multiply by E of
the face to get the stress.
The maximum distance from the
neutral axis, we can call c/2.
So that's y.
Then EI equivalent we had
Ef btc squared over 2.
And then I have a
term of Ef here.
c squared.
So one of the c's goes,
the 2's go, the Ef's go.
Then you just get that the
normal stress in the face
is the moment at
that section divided
by the width, b, the
face thickness, t,
the core thickness, c.
And I can do the
same kind of thing
for the stress in
the core, except now
I multiply by the core modulus.
So if I go through the
same kind of thing,
it's the same factor
of M over btc,
but now I multiply times E
of core over E of the face.
And since E of the core is a
lot smaller than E of the face,
typically these normal
stresses in the core
are much smaller than the
normal stresses in the face.
So the faces carry almost
all of the normal stresses.
And if you look at an I-beam,
the flanges of the I-beam
carry almost the
normal stresses.
So I want to do one
more thing here.
I want to relate the moment
to some concentrated load.
So let's say we have a beam
with a concentrated load, P.
So for example, something
in three-point bending,
typically we're interested
in the maximum stresses,
so we want the maximum moment.
So M max is going to be P
times l over some number.
And this B3 is another constant
that depends on the loading
configuration.
So if it was three-point
bending, B3 would be 4.
If it was a cantilever,
B3 would be 1.
So if I put those
things together,
the normal stress in the
face is Pl B3 divided by btc.
OK, so that's the
normal stresses.
And then the next thing
is the shear stresses,
and the shear stresses are
going to be carried largely
by the core.
And if you do all the
exact calculations,
they vary parabolically
through the core.
But if we make those
same approximations
that the face is stiff
compared to the core,
and that the face is thin
then you can say that
the shear stress is
just constant through the core.
So we'll say the shear
stresses vary parabolically
through the core.
But if the face is much
stiffer than the core
and the core is much
thicker than the face,
then you can say that the
shear stress in the core
is just equal to the sheer force
over the area of the core, bc.
So here, V is the shear
force of the cross-section
you're interested in.
And bc is just the
area of the core.
And we could say the
maximum shear force is just
going to be V over--
actually, let's make it
P, P over yet another constant.
And B4 also depends on
the loading configuration.
So if I was giving
you a problem,
I would give you all these B1,
B2, B3, B4's and everything.
So the maximum shear
stress in the core
is in just the applied
load, P, divided by this B4
and divided by the
area of the core.
OK, so this next figure
up here just shows
those stress distributions.
So here's a piece of
the cross-section here.
So there's the face thickness
and the core thickness.
You can think of that as a piece
along the length, if you want.
This is the normal stress
distribution, here.
So this is all
really from saying
plane sections remain plane.
These are the stresses, the
normal stresses in the core.
And you can see
they're a lot smaller
in this schematic than
the ones in the face.
And then this is the
parabolic stress in the core.
And similarly, there'd be a
different parabola in the face.
And these are the
approximations.
Typically these
approximations are
made so the normal
stress in the face
is just taken as a constant.
The normal stress in the
core is often neglected.
And here the shear stress in the
core is just a constant here.
So the two things you
need to worry about
are the normal
stress for the face
and the shear
stress for the core.
Are we good?
We're good?
Yeah, good-ish.
OK, so if we want to talk
about the strength of the beam,
we now have to talk about
different failure modes.
And the next slide just
shows some schematics
of the failure modes.
So there's different
ways the beam can fail.
Say it's in three-point
bending just
for the sake of convenience.
One way it can fail is,
say it had aluminum faces.
This face here
would be in tension,
and the face could just yield.
So you could just get
yielding of the aluminum.
That would be one way.
It could be a
composite face and you
could have some sort of
composite failure mode.
You can get more complicated
failure modes for composites,
but there could be some
sort of failure mode.
This face up here
is in compression,
and if you compress
that face, you
can get something
called face wrinkling.
You get sort of a
local buckling mode.
So imagine you have the face,
that you're pressing on it,
but the core is kind of acting
like an elastic foundation
underneath it.
And you can get this
kind of local buckling,
and that's called wrinkling.
That's another mode of failure.
You can also get the
core failing in shear.
So here's these two little
cracks, denoting shear failure
in the core.
And there's a couple of
other modes you can get,
but we're going to not pay
much attention to those.
The whole thing can delaminate,
and, as you might guess,
if the whole thing delaminates,
you're in deep doo-doo.
Because, remember when I
passed those samples around,
how flexible the face
was by itself and how
flexible the core is by itself.
If the whole thing
delaminates, you
lose that whole sandwich
effect and the whole thing
kind of falls apart.
We're going to assume
we have a perfect bond
and that we don't have
to worry about that.
The other sort of
failure mode you can get
is called indentation.
So imagine that you
apply this load here
over a very small area.
The load can just
transfer straight
through the face and
just kind of indent
the core underneath it.
We're going to assume
that you distribute
this load over a big
enough area here,
that you don't indent the core.
So we're going to worry about
these three failure modes
here-- the face yielding,
the face wrinkling,
and the core failing
and shear, OK?
So let me just write that down.
And then you also can have
debonding or delamination,
and we're going to
assume perfect bond.
And then you can
have indentation,
and we're going to
assume the loads are
applied over a large enough
area that you don't get--
So you can have different
modes of failure,
and the question becomes which
mode is going to be dominant?
So whichever one occurs
at the lowest load
is going to be the
dominant failure mode.
So you'd like to know what
that lowest failure mode is.
So we want to write equations
for each of these failure modes
and then figure out
which one occurs first.
So we'll look at the
face yielding here.
And face yielding is
going to occur just
when the normal
stress in the face
is equal to the yield
stress of the face.
So this is fairly
straightforward.
So this was our equation
for the stress in the face.
And when that's equal to
the face yield strength,
then you'll get failure.
And the face wrinkling occurs
when the normal compressive
stress in the face equals
a local buckling stress.
And people have worked
that out by looking
at what's called buckling
on an elastic foundation.
So the core acts
as elastic support.
You can think that
as the face is
trying to buckle into
the core, the core
is pushing back on the face.
And so the core is acting like
a spring that pushes back,
and that's called an
elastic foundation.
So people have calculated
this local buckling stress,
and they found
that's equal to 0.57
times the modulus of the
face to the 1/3 power
core to the 2/3 power.
And here, if we use our
model for open cell foams,
we can say the core modulus goes
as the relative density squared
times the solid modulus.
And so you can
plug that in there.
So then the
wrinkling occurs when
the stress in the face,
the Pl over the B3 btc
is equal to this thing here.
OK, so one more
failure mode that's
the core shear, and that's going
to occur when the shear stress
in the core is just equal to
the sheer strength of the core.
So the shear stress
is P over B4 times bc,
and the shear strength is some
constant, I think it's C11,
times the relative density of
the core to the three halves
power times the yield
strength of the solid.
And here, this constant
is about equal to 0.15,
something like that.
So now we have a
set of equations
for the different
failure modes, and we
could solve each of them,
not in terms of a stress,
but in terms of a load
P. The load P is what's
applied to the beam, right?
So we could solve each of
these in terms of the load, P.
And then we can see which one
occurs at the lowest load, P.
And that's going to be
the dominant failure mode.
So one way to do it would
be to, for every time
you wanted to do this, to work
out all these three equations
and figure out which
one's the lowest load.
But there's actually something
called a failure mode
map, which we're
going to talk about.
So let me just show you
it and we'll start now.
I don't know if we'll
get finished this.
But there's a way that you
can manipulate these equations
and plot the results as
this failure mode map.
And you'll end up plotting
the core density on this plot,
on this axis here, and the face
thickness to span ratio here,
and so this will
kind of tell you,
for different configurations
of the beam, different designs,
for these ones here, the
face is going to wrinkle,
for those ones there, the
face is going to yield,
and for these ones here,
the core is going to shear.
So I'm going to work
through these equations,
but I don't think we're
going to finish it today.
So this is just kind
of where we're headed
is to getting this map.
So we'll say the dominant
failure mode is the one that
occurs at the lowest load.
So the question
we're going to answer
is how does the failure mode
depend on the beam design?
And we're going to
do this by looking
at the transition from one
failure mode to another.
So at the transition
from one mode to another,
the two modes occur
at the same load.
So I'm going to
take those equations
I had for each of
the failure modes,
and instead of writing
this in terms of, say,
the stress in the face,
I'm going to write it
in terms of the
load, P. So using
that first one over there,
the load for face yielding,
I'm just rearranging that.
It's B3 times bc times t/l times
the yield strength of the face.
And similarly for
face wrinkling,
I can take this equation down
here and solve it for this P
here, OK?
And then I can take
that equation at the top
and solve that for P2
for the core shear,
and that's equal to C11
times B4 times bc times
sigma ys times--
oops, wrong thing--
times the relative
density to the 2/3 power.
OK?
And then the next step
is to equate these guys.
So you get a transition
from one mode to the other
when two of these guys are
equal to each other, right?
So there's going to be
a transition from face
yielding to face wrinkling
when these guys are equal.
And I'm not going to
start that because we're
going to run out of time.
But let me just say that I
can pair these two up and say
there's a transition
between those two.
And that transition is going
to correspond to this line
here, OK?
So at this line here, that
means you get face yielding
and face wrinkling
at the same load, OK?
And then if I paired
up-- let's see here.
If I paired up face wrinkling
and core shear, these two guys
here, I'm going to get this
equation here on that plot.
And then if I paired up
these two guys here, the face
shielding and the core shear, I
would get that line there, OK?
So once I have those lines,
that tells me, you know,
anything with a lower density
core and a smaller face
thickness is going to
fail by face wrinkling.
Anything with a
bigger density is
going to fail by face yielding.
And anything with a larger face
thickness and a larger density
is going to fail
by core shearing.
And so you can start
to see that it--
I'll work out the
equations next time,
but you can start to see that
it kind physically makes sense.
Intuitively, this
face wrinkling,
it depends on the normal stress
in the face, in compression.
So obviously the thinner the
face gets, the more likely
that's going to be to happen.
So it's going to happen at
this end of the diagram.
And it also depends on that
elastic foundation, on how much
spring support the
foundation has, right?
So the lower the core
density, the more likely
that is to happen.
Then if you, say you have
small t, so the face is going
to fail before the core, as
you increase the core density,
you're making that elastic
foundation stiffer and stiffer,
and you're making it harder
for the buckling to occur.
It can't buckle into
the elastic foundation,
so then you're going to
push it up to the yielding.
And then as you make the
face thickness bigger,
as t gets bigger, then the
face isn't going to fail
and the core is going to fail.
So you can kind of
see just looking
at the relative position
of those things,
they all kind of
make physical sense.
So I'm going to
stop there for today
and I'll finish the
equations for that next time.
And we'll also talk
about how to optimize
for strength next time.
And we'll talk about a few
other things on sandwich panels.